this is the most gangster [__] dude
finally a company that doesn't give a
[__] for real dude and we should have
known all along it was going to be
Arby's we should have known all along
that that [__] was going to be Arby's
dude you know why because Arby's is
Gangster do you know
why because
Arby's uh is so
um like who goes to Arby's right have
you have you met by the way have you
ever met some that went to Arby's if you
have then you know you're so if if you
know some like it it's like this the
people who go to Arby's now for sure
Midwestern is [__] right even if the
Arby's are in La like if you know
somebody that
is that has been to an Arby's you are
from the Midwest if you know someone who
knows someone that is from Arby's you
might not be from the Midwest like 80%
chance and then if you know someone who
you know someone who you know someone
who went to Arby's like 60% it keeps
dropping and dropping and dropping it's
like the Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon it's
like the six degrees of Arby's right
um so they had to do something they had
to get out of that [__] bubble dude
because McDonald's is worldwide right
Burger King that be worldwide Taco Bell
be worldwide Arby's might be worldwide
but it's not really in the Lexicon right
when you mentioned fast food you don't
think Arby well they changed all that
finally somebody did a [__] gangster
[__] they took push te who used to do
[__] for McDonald's and made a diss
track on a commercial for Arby's against
McDonald's can I even play it I don't
know maybe we can if if it Flags I put
this on the
patreon now
I you should be disgusted how dare you
asking us to trust a half slice of
cheese Mickey on a
budg COR we might a eggs stage left the
sandwich taste fresh listen to this song
and
get
Bas arent is Bess drowned and of that
feto fish is tast see only deals in the
greatness I bet the house on it like his
Vegas God he's good
I you think fa yeah theis fish sandwi
blings clown just too this is the best
part right here if know me and you know
me
is going scale he put in a Coke
reference he put in a oh he put in a
Coke reference oh it's
all he put in a [__] Coke
reference he put in a [__] reference
about cocaine on a [__] worldwide
mainstream
commercial push a t that's why he's they
call him push a cuz he pushes the
limit dude oh he pushed the [__] Coke
reference into a goddamn 30 second spot
they're going to run on
TV dude and that's what you need to do
now I've been saying this [__] companies
needs to grab some nuts but they [__]
nutted up didn't they Arby's nutted it
up Arby's [__] straight up grabbed
their nuts and just looked at these
[__] corporate [__] and was
like you know what [__] it dude let's
make a diss track whoever F and I'm
telling you now all of a sudden Arby is
in the conversation
dude Arby wasn't in the conversation
before this dropped and now it is and
it's just
like we wanted it all
along this is what we wanted from
Corporate America all along now don't
get mistaken they're still just trying
to sell sauce and their own fish
biscuits but still though this is a move
towards greatness and when Arby's wanted
to be in the discussion I just simply go
like
this
he worked a Coke reference into a
mainstream
commercial so push a t is the killer
dude push a t is the McDonald's killer
didn't he come up with like [__] bada
papaya or some [__] he came up with some
jingle for McDonald's and they didn't
pay him so he made a diss track for the
other comp for the by the way they
weren't even the competitor but now they
are McDonald's answer get Bun B on a
track dude answer pay Jay-Z pay
[__] Drake pay him [__] that
I'll go in and all Arby's now I'm going
to eat all the [__] Arby's I wonder
if I can play that commercial on the
[__] you think I
can dude I need to [__] eat all of
Arby's That's So Dope that they did that
and he worked a Coke reference in it
just next one should just be you know me
snorting up all the coke at
arbee boom boom boom brought my hook of
the arz and she had my
Coke boom took my dick out and started
pissing all over
[Music]
I'm with Alex Jones and we [__] hate
we hate everyone that's not us abom boom
boom the vaccine is fake it doesn't work
at all abom boom
boom dude are you kidding me hell yeah
dude [__] yeah dude this is the [__]
that needs to happen I'm telling you
it's on its way anyway you can push it
you can or you can try to make pretend
like it's not going to push like you
could go ahead and you could keep making
your [__] stupid Charming commercials
with the purple bear or you can act like
these [__] are coming for your
head and one's true and one's not Mike
Tyson made gummy
ears okay because he beat Evander how
the [__] you think Evander hfield feels
about that probably pretty
bad if he even understands that it's
happening because he's been boxed to the
[__] head his whole life and Shake a
lot but Mike Tyson was like yeah I his
ear let's put out gummy CBD ears
okay so you can act like the shit's not
coming but it's coming I'm telling you
in [__] 5 to 10 years there's going
to be a commercial where somebody
[__] literally stab
someone or like you
know oh no how do you oh no there's a
[__] peeping Tom and he's jerking off
in my window what the [__] and it's
going to be like an ADT commercial ADT
we're here for you if guys be jerking
off outside in your plant we're here for
you boom enough with the guys outside
jerking off boom boom boom Alex Jones is
this
[__] um so
anyway it's like you you can hurt people
you there's
you got it's only nice if you can hurt
people's feelings man I hate to say it
but that's where the bags that's where
the most bags
are the second you play it safe and play
it too calm I was I saw a flyer the
other day and it said like what the [__]
was it it was like uh for uh safe comedy
during these hard times and it was just
like huh but comedy huh but hold on
someone wants a word let them
in hi guys who are you I'm comedy can I
join not on this
show